former Senate Republican leader Bob Dole
delivered a powerful tribute to
President Bush after being helped to his
feet
95 year old doll a fellow World War two
veteran lost the Republican presidential
nomination to mr. Bush in 1988 and
competed against him in 1980 Dole called
the 41st president a cherished servant
leader and a dear friend that was one of
the most moving things I saw yesterday I
got a big lump watching because you
could see how much it meant to Bob Dole
to be there and to rise to his feet
absolutely that was really a beautiful
sight to see and to also think about the
service that Bob Dole is paid in this
country as well it was a moment for
everyone to see that CBS News will have
full coverage President George Herbert
Walker Bush his state funeral at
Washington National Cathedral our
special report begins at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern 9:00 central here on CBS special
counsel Robert Muller is recommending no
jail time for president Trump's former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
in court papers Muller cited Flynn's
quote substantial assistance with the
Russia investigation after he admitted
lying to the FBI
we sure Jiang's at the White House with
the significance of Flynn to Muller's
case we show good morning good morning
Gail last December Michael Flynn became
the first high-ranking Trump adviser to
agree to formally cooperate in the
special counsels Russia probe and even
though Robert molars court filing is
highly redacted it highlights the
massive scope of information flynn has
offered investigators prosecutors say
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn has been instrumental to the
special counsels investigation
participating in 19 interviews and
providing documents and communications
concerning links between the Russian
government and the Trump campaign an
early supporter of mr. Trump Flynn
admitted last December to lying to the
FBI about passing messages between the
incoming administration and Russian
ambassador Sergei kiss lyac in December
2016 and Flynn was forced out as
national security adviser after he lied
to vice president pence about those
communications who at the time defended
on Face the Nation what I can confirm
having spoken to him about it is that
those conversations that happen to occur
around the time that the United States
took took action to expel diplomats had
nothing whatsoever to do with those
sanctions the witch-hunt as I call it
should never have taken place the White
House has been calling for the Muller
probe to wrap up as quickly as possible
but the heavy redactions indicate Muller
could be far from finished Muller has
very much remains on the job his sleeves
rolled up Harry Lippmann is a former US
Attorney and Deputy Assistant Attorney
General under President Clinton Flynn is
an ideal position to sort of explain to
Muller what were the stakes within the
White House that that made it so
important from Trump's own personal
viewpoint to try to smother the
investigation and there's more to come
this week from the special counsels
office by Friday we expect Mueller's
team to also file memos revealing new
details about former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort and the
president's former personal attorney
Michael Cohen Norah much more to come
indeed Thank You EJ